YACINE REZGUI:
Android Studio 3.4
is now available for download
on the stable channel,
along with version 3.4 of the
Android plugin for Gradle.
This version of Android Studio
fixes a number of issues
and add few new features,
a resource manager,
new capabilities to the
project structure dialogue,
and enables R8, our new
[INAUDIBLE] by default.
This release is an
incremental quality release
as part of Project Marble.
And it's specifically
light on new features
in order to fix primarily
on bug fixes and quality.
Stay tuned for even
more on Project Marble
updates in the 3.5 release.
The resource manager
is a new tool
that helps you manage your
application in drawable colors
and layouts.
You can bulk import resource
files in your project,
convert SVGs into
vector drawables,
visualize your resource
without having to open them,
and even drag and drop drawables
from the resource manager
onto the Layout Editor.
Coinciding with the navigation
library stable release,
the navigation editor
in Android Studio
now supports all
type of arguments,
which mean no need to
manually edit your navigation
file for previously
unsupported types.
The project structure
dialog has been redesigned
and includes many
new improvements
to help reconfigure project
properties without manually
editing your vl-gradle files,
and includes rich UI support
for working with
module variables.
You can explore the dependency
graph of your project
within your resolve
dependencies view,
and use the suggestion page
to manage dependency conflicts
and updates.
If you start Jetpack and
Firebase classes in your code,
we added the new
intention action
that suggests adding the
required Gradle library
dependency to your project, if
you haven't already done so.
On the build side,
we have now made
R8 the default code
optimizer for Android
builds replacing ProGuard.
Previously, separated
tools were used
to handle different stages
of compilation, desugaring
of Java class
files, dexing, code
shrinking, and optimizations
making the build process
longer.
Android Studio 3.1 introduced
D8, a new code dexer
that takes on desugaring
and transforming class
files into Dalvik Bytecode.
With Android Gradle
plugin 3.4 and higher,
we are replacing of the
last part, code shrinking
and optimization with
R8, a single tool that
combines the functionality
D8 and ProGuard,
resulting in noticeable build
performance improvements.
Keep in mind, R8 is designed
to work with your existing
ProGuard rules.
So you should not need to make
any changes to start using R8.
We tested against the
center tracker project,
and the shrinking plus
dexing time was nearly 50%
faster than using ProGuard.
R8 supports Android
library project as well.
If you experience issues
using R8 when building AARs,
please report a
bug on our tracker.
You can also disable R8 for
only Android library projects
with this code in
your Gradle file.
By default, R8 works as
a drop-in replacement
for ProGuard by running
in a compatibility mode.
There is also a
full mode available
which enables more optimization,
but the compatibility
with ProGuard is
no longer assured.
You can enable the full mode by
adding this line to your Gradle
property file.
If you're still using the
com.Android feature plug-in
to build your instant app,
Android Gradle plug-in 3.4
will show you a
deprecation warning.
To make sure you can still
build your instant app
on future versions
of the plugin,
migrate your Instant App to
the dynamic feature plugin.
Doing so allows you to build
and publish a single instant
enabled Android
App Bundle for both
the instant and installed
versions of your app.
When building native libraries,
ndkCompile is now deprecated.
And it will produce a build
error if you try to use it.
You should instead use either
CMake or ndk-build to add C
and C++ code to your project.
Enjoy Android Studio
3.4, and remember
that we are listening to your
feedback on our bug tracker.
You can test early builds
of Android Studio 3.5
on the [INAUDIBLE] channel.
See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]